muchísima atención en todo el país como
tú lo mencionabas esto es justo frente a
la asamblea nacional en la Plaza de la
Concordia donde en este mismo momento
acaban de comenzar a desplegarse los
agentes de la gendarmería y también
oficiales de los cuerpos republicanos de
seguridad en aparente preparación para
lo que puede suceder aquí más tarde hoy
si tenemos en cuenta que la Plaza de la
Concordia ha sido sede en los últimos
dos días de grandes manifestaciones de
enfrentamientos con la policía cerca de
cuatro mil personas por ejemplo anoche
pues es el lógico que comience ya el
despliegue de los agentes del orden en
el acceso de los campos elíseos hay
también desplegados en varios camiones
de policía es necesario mencionar que
durante toda la jornada ha ocurrido
movilizaciones en otras partes del país
puedo mencionar algunas ciudades como
conpioña nantes lecané cerca de cannes
El Abre estrasburgo burdeos toulouse en
todas estas ciudades en este momento
están ocurriendo acciones de protestas Y
por supuesto las huelgas sobre todo las
más importantes en el sector de la
energía porque es vital este sector para
el funcionamiento de cualquier país las
refinería más grande de Francia que se
encuentra en normandía podría ser
completamente detenida por los
huelguistas desde hoy entre hoy y el
lunes esto a este movimiento se va a
sumar también las las refinería de
petrolneos en la zona en la costa
mediterránea francesa y hay también
varios depósitos de combustible
bloqueados en este minuto Cómo responde
el gobierno completamente desafiante sí
efectivamente se detienen estas
refinerías sí efectivamente se bloquean
los depósitos de combustible el gobierno
enviará allí agentes del orden a
requisicionar los lugares y las personas
que deben operar esas instalaciones
desde el punto de vista de transporte
también hay trenes y varias líneas de
gran velocidad afectadas hoy cerca de
30% de los vuelos cancelados a petición
de las autoridades de la Aviación civil
y por supuesto no podemos dejar de
mencionar también los recolectores de
basura aquí en París por ejemplo Hemos
llegado ya a la cerca de Diez mil
toneladas de desperdicios en las calles
sin recoger